I have never bought anything so fast in
my life this is a color changing s sorry
to ruin everyone's fun but these
products are absolutely a gimmick they
don't adjust or adapt to your skin tone
they're just a sheer Foundation if you
look at the ingredients the pigments
here are just the same red yellow and
black ion oxides that you see in almost
every foundation and tinted product
they've just encapsulated them so it's
sort of like they wrap them into little
tiny popping Boba except the outside is
white when you rub it they burst and
it's not like it's adjusting to the
white paper or anything it's just the
same colored pigment I guess it is kind
of blending in with your skin but that's
just because it's got less pigment and
so more of your skin color shows through
and so every less pigmented product is
going to work on more skin tones just
because it's covering your skin less it
just seems pretty dishonest to sell it
that way it's like saying if a normal
moisturizer adjust to everyone's skin
tone because there's no pigment in it